let's follow up about that crazy chrony
swamp filling swamp job the 300 million
dollar contract that was given to
Whitefish energy if you forgot about the
story if you didn't see us cover this
story if you missed it if you
deliberately didn't pay attention to it
because it's so vile and disgusting
there's this small energy company in
Whitefish Montana they had two full-time
employees at the time of the puerto
rican hurricanes that knocked out power
in Puerto Rico and they concocted this
online presence with 100 positive
reviews all in the three days before
they were awarded by the Trump
administration a 300 million dollar
contract to get the power turned back on
in Puerto Rico now right away a number
of media outlets started to look into
this because it's weird right two
full-time employees in Whitefish Montana
and you get the contract to restore all
of the power in Puerto Rico and then it
was revealed that Trump's interior
secretary Ryan Zinke was from this exact
same is from this exact same town
Whitefish Montana it was revealed that
people associated with the company and
the company's investors were big big
donors to Donald Trump and we realized
this is a total swamp job total utter
swamp job Puerto Rico and the Governor
of Puerto Rico decided to cancel the
contract and rightly so and I said last
week investigate this investigate what
happened here and reportedly that is
happening according to The Wall Street
Journal the FBI is now investigating the
300 million-dollar white fish energy
contract in Puerto Rico white fish
energy the last I read said that they
are unaware of the investigation the FBI
as they typically do is not confirming
nor denying that this investigation
exists but I really hope that this is
happening and the F the Trump
administration Trump talks about
shrinking government the Trump
administration itself might require the
FBI to go on a hiring spree merely to
keep up with all the different elements
that need to be investigated as a result
of Donald Trump being in the Oval Office
and being President of the United States
next announcement from Trump is going to
be I have decided to save the American
taxpayer a lot of money big bucks folks
truly
I'm disbanding the FBI we are gonna save
billions of dollars every single year
and of course the need for this
investigation is obvious that the only
question I have with every single one of
these investigations is will will
anything come of it are we ever really
going to hear you know what it was a
swamp job it was a crony capitalist
lobbyist whatever you want to call it
and we are going to hold people
accountable for it probably not and part
of it is that you rarely see these types
of investigations lead to actual
indictments because it's all it's all
sketchy but it becomes difficult to
prove guilt and you often don't really
see it go anywhere but my concern amid
this investigation and of course this
has nothing to do with the FBI is when
is Puerto Rico going to have power fully
back on because at this point it's been
how long has it even been since the
Hurricanes it's been a more than a month
right I mean the three five weeks at six
seven weeks since the the the start of
this that series of three four
hurricanes that we had when is Puerto
Rico going to have power fully back on
we have no idea it's not going
particularly well and I can't get this
image out of my head that if the
military had been called in to invade
Puerto Rico that we would have gotten
the power back on we would have the
power available we would have generators
we would have figured out a way to get
the grid back up we would have somehow
figured it out if we needed the power on
for the military to invade but somehow
we can't seem to actually get it done
and we've got 300 million dollar swamp
job crony capitalist contracts going to
trump donors in the hometown of trump's
interior secretary ryan's inky and just
full disclosure just I don't want to I
don't want to be accused of leaving
things out that that are potentially
exculpatory Trump's interior secretary
Ryan's inky has said that he was not
involved in this contract that could
mean anything or nothing at all right
Ryan's inky could have been the person
who introduced the people from Whitefish
energy to whoever was ultimately in
charge of deciding the contract so by
the letter
Ryan's Enki is right he wasn't involved
in a decision about that contract but he
might have been the one who introduced
these people we just don't know
so yeah Ryan Zinke said that but that
could be absolutely and totally
meaningless